lg has always been known for its stellar
displays from great televisions to
pristine monitors but what makes the
airspace so special after all most folks
only need a screen unless your goal is
to take your setup to the next level and
create an ergonomic space for your
comfort after all most of us spend at
least seven hours a day in front of the
computer and comfort definitely is
everything that's why we're here to help
hello everyone i'm zacchi back for
another video here geek culture we cover
plenty of tech and gadgets so the next
video might be different from this
before you go thanks for hanging around
and subscribe if you enjoyed this video
today we have the beautiful and stunning
27 inch 4k ips display from lg which not
only looks great but it also has some
pretty impressive top-notch features
including hdr 10-bit color gamut and its
own ergo monitor stand and i gotta tell
y'all
this display does everything i need and
then some we are talking about video
editing photo editing surfing the web
streaming tv shows and movies and i'll
be sharing my thoughts on this display
and if you like to learn more about this
device do check out the link in the
description below so let's get started
the lg ultrafine 27un880b
is a 27 inch standard display it's a
sleek and surprisingly light device and
you've got three sided borderless bezels
which gives this monitor a nice modern
aesthetic to it
think of it like a content creator's
display you know the kind of monitor you
see in the thumbnails with non-existing
cables yeah and it's really clean and
what i really like about this display is
that out of the box it comes with an
ergo stand with a c-type clamp which
mounts onto any desk or table surface
now it can extend and retract across a
depth of 180 millimeters tilt up to 25
degrees left and right swivel up to 280
degrees adjust the screen height at a
range of 130 millimeters
and be placed in landscape or portrait
mode and the best part is that it's all
included in the box with minimal setup
the stand is really solid and sturdy
with the one click mount feature so all
it takes is just one person no
additional tools to get this up and
running fairly quickly i like the fact
that the c-type clamp is able to be used
on a very thin desk as well as the
massive ones now some of them are
several inches in thickness and if that
isn't suitable for you lg has also
supplied a t-type clamp so that you can
mount the stand through the desk making
it even more subtle while also freeing
up room that would otherwise be taken up
by
a stand now just by looking at this you
can already see that the design of the
stand is impressive it's functional it's
minimal and it frees up extra space for
accessories and charges on your desk now
adjusting the monitor is easy without
any resistance but not too fluid that
the stand moves on its own it also
offers cable management integrated
within the stand here and provides a
more streamlined look once you've tucked
all the cables in now lg has really made
a great arm here and imagine if you need
to change the monitor position around
and show a colleague your screen it all
can be done effortlessly
do have a look at how the entire range
of motion the monitor can go through as
it glides across your desk now looking
at the back of the display we can see a
100 by 100 mm visa mount support and a
slew of ports including two hdmi 2.0 two
usb a 3.1
a displayport 1.4 a 3.5 mm headphone out
and of course a usb type-c
one thing of note here is the usb 3.2
type-c port which is a powerful port
that comes with a wealth of benefits
it's useful if you're powering up your
devices or even for data transfer but
what i love is the fact i can use the
usb type-c port as a second display for
my tablets or in this case with the mac
studio this usb type-c port will help
you keep things clean and tidy without
having multiple cables lying around and
it doesn't stop there lg doesn't skimp
on the specs either now this display
offers an ips panel which is the most
prevalent for professional displays
ips panels are perfect for color
reproduction and accuracy thanks to its
10 bit color scheme and srgb 99 coverage
so for media professionals like myself i
steer towards having ips panels as my
daily driver for video and photo editing
in terms of brightness you are getting
350 nits for this display which is a
good compromise between price and
performance
and you can expect to use this during
the daytime it's a good choice to use it
in well-lit rooms because it gets bright
enough to fight glare and has great
reflection handling hdr support here is
very much welcomed and makes a
noticeable difference when it comes to
improve color accuracy and contrast
to ensure you're getting a powerful
machine here are a few things to look
out for for image quality and
performance i'm using the custom one
picture mode on default mode with
brightness on a hundred percent now this
checks all the boxes of what a high
priced professional display would be you
get 3840 by 2160 resolution at 60 hertz
with a 5 millisecond response time which
is gonna be optimal for work and
productivity but how sharp is it exactly
well if you put it in portrait mode
that's where you get a real sense of how
sharp text are on display when reading
long pdfs and emails putting it through
its basis in lightroom colors are deep
and rich but not too overpowering images
come out very clean and renders images
colors and text with stunning clarity
the same points can be said when it
comes to video editing on premiere pro
as well
now color is an important part of video
and photo editing and scene colors is
incredibly important now everyone's
screen displays color and contrast
differently so it's best for a creator
to have a monitor that lets you see an
image as accurate as possible this way
it is guaranteed to look good on any
display even if the image does get
altered in some way now one thing to
note and this is more on a personal
preference and budget but when it comes
to my workflow i do like to have more
real estate when working so in my case i
have a dual monitor set up with the lg
27un880b
as my main monitor for easy referencing
and coloring while the other is to work
on my timelines
so for those who share the same
preference you might want to opt for the
32 inch version if your wallet is up for
it when it comes to gaming the lg 27un
a80b comes with amd freezing technology
which reduces screen tearing and this
does help out with having smoother
visuals while gaming now this lg monitor
is by no means a gaming monitor but is
perfectly capable for single player
games or casual gaming where input lag
doesn't matter all that much
it should do well if you want to hook up
a gaming console to it and take a break
from work now with that said this is
still mainly a productivity used monitor
and this would not be advised for
competitive gaming with its 5
milliseconds response time
now if you're looking for a gaming
monitor there is also the lg 32 gp850b
which performs at a higher refresh rate
and response time
all in all there is a lot to tout about
the lg ultrafine ergo display but at its
core it's all about form and function i
just love the flexibility it provides
and i'm amazed at how much i am able to
adjust the ergo stand which is
especially important when you are
working in a collaborative environment
the lg27un880b
is priced at 899 singapore dollars or
1099 singapore dollars for the 32-inch
version you can check out the full list
of merchants in the description
below the lg ultra fine
27un880b is perfect for anyone who is
spending lots of time on the computer or
even during collaborative moments where
one would share screens and take notes
now if you're looking for something
minimal and clean looking this is
definitely a monitor one should consider
and it does save you the hassle of
additional accessories since the ergo
stand is bundled together with the
monitor alrighty we hope you enjoyed
this video if you have any questions
drop them down in the comments below we
love to hear from you do smash the like
button and the bell icon so you can stay
updated with our latest videos till next
time this is zacky marios
[Music]
you